when I was 10 years old I I was living
in Panama and my dad took me into our
living room and he told me that he was a
covert operative with the CIA and swore
me to secrecy you can imagine for a
ten-year-old it's like telling somebody
it's like telling your son that you're
the Lone Ranger but they can't tell any
of their friends I I have a daughter
who's three and she thinks I work at the
Metro because that's where I'm always
getting picked up after work I don't
know if I have the heart to break it to
her that I'm a criminal defense lawyer
the story of my parents spans 50 years
five kids four countries three wars a
revolution two races and one faith only
then did death do the party it's the
story of a man who was part of the
greatest generation ever told we hear a
lot about the folks in World War two
deservedly well we don't always hear
about those silent soldiers that fought
in this nations cold war nor did we hear
about their wives and families this is
not just a story about my father it's
also a story of a remarkable woman a
woman who used the most traditional of a
female role for the most unconventional
events helping my father recruit spies
for the Central Intelligence Agency it's
also the story of a young girl from
Baltimore who left into this marriage
and then 29 years later was a seasoned
CIA wife who had befriended ministers
wives
and greeted manuel noriega at the door
at midnight it was this woman who when
my father was dying of cancer was that
sloan-kettering when the hospital
officials told her that he had to go
they had done everything they could for
my father and space was needed it was
then that she didn't cry she didn't
threaten she didn't grandstand she
didn't control
she asked for a meeting and at that
meeting with the head of sloan-kettering
there and the two physicians who cared
for my father she secreted from her
purse a small tape recorder and pressed
record as she said doctors the meeting
may begin my father stayed meet my mom
good evening it's nice to see all of you
it's a real pleasure I'm pleased to see
a little boy who said he was interested
in the book and even stayed for the
reading my Spy is more than a book it's
a promise kept I promise that I made to
my husband 24 years ago as he lay dying
he wanted to stand up and be counted
CIA had taken an awful lot of flak and
Joe was sick of going under the cover of
big Department of the army civilian or
foreign service officer he wanted it
known that he was a spy and he was proud
of it
so there was sitting next to Joe's bed
while he dictated the events of our
secret lives that we live together and
there it was that for the first time I
met the husband I'd never really found I
like take you back 54 years to the
University of Michigan 1946 it was right
after the war and you know Japanese
weren't terribly popular at that time
Joe was studying law Michigan I was an
undergraduate and he was 8 and a half
years my senior we were both engaged to
somebody else at the time so when the
exchange dinner came up for us
this brother dorms to meet I didn't sign
up because I was engaged but that didn't
slow Joe up at any rate we signed and I
understand that his name was Killa Naga
and I assumed it was Italian maybe never
dreaming that when I went to the dinner
I would be faced with a six foot four
handsome Japanese as I looked across
that Lobby and that's very moments I
knew the reason I've been born
when you're hot you're hot the
microphones no problem
not being spied on or anything nice
so there we had a japanese-american from
a tiny island Pacific Molokai was only
about its only claim to fame was that it
housed a leper colony and there I was an
Irish Catholic redhead from Baltimore
that should have been the end of the
story but was just the beginning
Joe didn't have much money so he took me
on a lot of walls at the end of the walk
we'd we'd go to the corner drugstore and
split a can of chicken noodle soup and
on our third walk Joe turned to me and
said fine it'll never work and I said
sure well Joe and just like that we were
engaged and that's how I ended up with a
man that every girl wanted the date but
no one had the guts to marry and that's
how I ended up plunked down in the
middle of the Pacific it was our sign of
paradise just the two of us actually no
make that three of us Joe me and his
mother a mother-in-law is bad enough a
Japanese mother-in-law is absolute
disaster we should have just remained
pen pals but one good thing did come out
of Hawaii we had a baby girl her name
was Mary and she was beautiful she had
red hair in front black and back and I
figured well that's what comes of a
mixed marriage Joe and I traded in the
balmy winds of Waikiki the deep freeze
of a cold war in Washington he was going
to study at sighs he was going to get
his degree his master's degree in
international relations but we faced the
challenge we couldn't buy an apartment
again remember that's when the Japanese
were not very popular and they tell us
that there were no vacancies when actual
reason was that they didn't want
japanese so finally we've ran into a war
buddy of jose out in the virginia at
four corners and they let us have an
apartment
joe had served in the 442 in europe the
japanese-american regimental combat team
he was decorated for fowler and he got a
field Commission next thing we needed
was a job and CIA offered him a job and
Joe it's kind of excited because it
sounded so mysterious
super secret and a little exotic and so
he joined because he thought it would be
an extension of his World War two
experience CIA really did it up Brown in
those days travel was wonderful and our
first trip was to our first posting
Japan and we went on the SS President
Cleveland it was it was something like
out of a Somerset Maugham novel it was
so so lovely for some reason if I if I
hadn't been in love before I would have
fallen in love with Joe on that ship
somehow the lime seemed lime here the
wind seemed windier the dinnertime
conversation more battered it was just
perfect perfect until we got to Yokohama
after 14 days I looked out the porthole
and I thought have I come all this
distance just to wind up in the Asian
version of Oliver everything it was gray
it was it was war-torn industrial
industrious and just plain ugly I
thought if this is Japan I'm not gonna
like it but wait maybe it wasn't so bad
after all our car took us to Kamakura to
our new home on the coast and there it
was perched on a cliff over the Pacific
are quasi mansion that CIA had gotten
for us and it was windswept gardens food
and the larder fresh linens on the beds
it was just wonderful
it was wonderful until the next morning
I awakened late to dead silence in the
house
there's no Joe oh I saw Ivan with a
little note he'd left saying that the
driver picked him up at seven o'clock
he'd be back around 8:00 that evening
great just great I am with two little
children David had been born recently
didn't speak a word of the language no
telephone no money no clue what to do
welcome to the CIA
for 28 years I lived a lie and I didn't
like it at first we died about our
husbands jobs stalled inquisitive
policemen befriended ministers wives
kept our ears open at parties deflected
the children's questions and worried in
silence alone
we were the CIA wives you never even
knew us I tend to be kind of gregarious
I'm curious I kind of enjoy the
limelight and here I was in Japan I
couldn't I couldn't be for guys couldn't
talk I didn't know what was going on and
Joe whenever he'd come home and I was
upset where had he been he'd just go
like this in other words don't say
anything it infuriated me I also I
couldn't ask questions he'd be gone for
days at a time
unannounced and come back unannounced
and I couldn't say where have you been
you know also one time I glimpsed them
out of the corner my taking off in
battle fatigues
it seems he'd been in Korea at the front
at the height of the Korean War all this
I learned later but if it had a bad side
that I found not being able to talk not
being able to question I got pretty
lonely and I wasn't at all happy with my
lot I felt that all the loops I mean if
I was a CIA wife I want this be part of
the action and everything was so far in
and strange it was the language was
different the culture was different the
people all look so different and I was
not sophisticated enough to realize it
to be charmed and at first I was truly
alarmed and then there were the kids
there were no playmates for the kids we
had this beautiful place set off in the
hinterlands but there were no playmates
marry one time opened a vial on the
beach and I guess there was poison in it
I don't know what was in it
there was a vial and she drank it and I
took her to a
doctor nearby a Japanese doctor trying
to explain to him what had happened and
he took a rubber hose one from the
garden and started to Ram it down her
throat
you know the cleanser stomach I mean
it's that sort of thing I was flying
blind and it was scary it was weird
that's that was the beginning and then
to wake at 3:00 a.m. with a sick child
it's kind of scary when your husband's
off once God knows doing what you know I
mean he could have been cavorting it was
a gay shore or climbing to Mount Fuji I
don't I don't know what he was doing
I'll tell you one thing you had to be
trusting to be a CIA wife you had to be
really trusting because you rather than
worry about your husband's safety when
he's gone for days at a time rather than
being upset that he might be maybe is
fooling around on you you don't know you
just have to trust it's very important
we were all part of a big conspiracy but
only Joe was in on the secret I can
understand now why James Bond never
married
ours was a product of a mixed and a
mixed up marriage it wasn't only
biracial
it was just kind of weird because it was
so secretive you know if it can't visit
you can't have a drink when your husband
comes home from work and it's not a bad
day and all that if you can't just visit
about it it's it's hard you can't share
as much I made it very difficult for me
we had our problems I wish we could take
back some of those painfully beautiful
Sundays or some of those magical
Saturday night parties spoiled because
we had the plaster smiles on our faces
what was our problem couldn't we see
that we'd been given so much great kids
a good career life overseas each other
and we're close to destroying it
couldn't we see that we were tempting
God in our quiet moments yes but how do
you stop yourself when you're hurt
furious
count to ten say a Hail Mary maybe that
helps but you need more you need
humility to calmly await your husband's
return not knowing where he is to
debrief a defector with critical
information those things are difficult
to admit that you're wrong
they asked forgiveness next to
impossible but we tried we tried to
fight the good fight we tried to keep
the faith
there was a good side to being a CIA
wife because as my son said a spies main
job is to recruit agents well what
better thing to do than me help them
recruit days and of course I never knew
who the agents were that was the problem
but I could I could at least garner some
information for him and that's when I
started to join various clubs try to get
on the board join the PTA as the
children grew and do things that gave me
entree to the local folk and it was
there that I began to make a few friends
for both of us and that's when the
really interesting part comes in the
parties that we would give it was all of
our parties had themes they were either
a Italian villa of Moroccan cash ball
whatever but everything had to be along
that scene the flowers the music the
menu I mean it's tough fighting
communism and somebody's got to play in
the menu so and along the way when we'd
have parties it would be nice if I
picked up a little information that
would help Joe like a cabinet minister
was it going to Washington no but I
understand his wife's going to Paris
that type of thing and oh by the way
doesn't say the son wants to study urban
planning Joseph hmm that's not a bad
idea
maybe I'll get him a scholarship that
would that would help so that's the sort
of thing that went on and a Catholic
Church and CIA have always worked hand
in glove and Joe had a lot of priest
agents actually I thought job Joe spent
an awful lot of time in church
it seems that he was meeting an agent in
the confessional
he'd go in and into one of the little
receptacles and he would open the
sliding door and for the agent was there
he'd go ahead and have a meeting but if
by chance if there was a priest there
Joe would confess his sins and that way
when he left he had something he at
least had either information or
absolution after Japan we were sent to
Brazil
if Japan taught me to be a good wife
Brazil taught me to enjoy it for us
Brazil was a dance on the beach a
knowing glance across the room all set
to the general Toto a bossa nova the
clink of ice Joe's drag on a cigarette
for the first time in my life I didn't
feel outrageous I loved it we loved it
sayonara Tokyo good night dear
Washington bond gia San Paolo what
contrast what is free
yin and yang hot and sour I tend to
equate a country in terms of taste
Japan enjoyed innate quiet good taste
Brazil's was flamboyant but no less
refined if Japan was a sublime
choreography of silent tea ceremony
Brazil was a careening samba parade but
you better watch your wallet everything
in Brazil is larger than life their
sunsets are surreal
their full moon is luminous to the point
of being airy and their southern cross
on a starlit night out sparkles any
possible diamond concoction the music
makes you makes you nostalgic even if
you've never heard it before and the
people everyone's having a good time and
it's contagious
I suspect that all Brazilians are born
relaxed you can see it in the way they
walk they just don't seem to take life
all that seriously
maybe it's because so much there
operates on faith God is certainly not
dead in Brazil I could see as much as we
flew into Rio while kamakura was
presided over by the dobutsu a huge
statue of christ without stretched arms
reigns over rio in fact they have a
saying God is a Brazilian the resulting
philosophy is to my mind dead on and
aspiring life is short it said God's
hands anyway so live it up brazil always
opens another bottle of wine
spines exciting work as a ripple effect
in the marriage feeling of suppressed
excitement so if your husband was off
cavorting for days at a time
when he finally did come home it was
well worth the wait but Joe felt that
being chief of station had to be the
most rewarding job in the world it was a
stressful job it also was a job that
leaves a lot of us widows next we were
assigned to Panama that's when the canal
negotiations were heating up
Manuel Noriega was all over the front
page of the local newspapers we did our
stride we were late bloomers we're going
to take it slow so we could taste some
vanilla like my grandmother Katie used
to say we were on top of the world
you cannot see the canal clays from the
waiting room of Balboa's Gorgas hospital
but in the Panama sky will hundreds of
birds gulls cormorants kites hawks and
buzzards I watch them from the window
until I saw the doctor coming toward me
his green operating gown wrinkled from
four hours of intensive work nose mask
dangling from one air with immense
wariness the doctor said mrs. kenig wa
it's bad I would have preferred thee
taking me aside to talk to me oh it's
just too public people whom I felt that
I'd known almost came to know during our
annual our waiting room vigil perked up
their ears misery loves company and I
had none no family no friends for the
first time I was facing bad though news
with no Joe beside me the doctor was a
good surgeon but no diplomat I had to
remove three-quarters of your husband's
stomach I'm quite sure it's cancer it
may have spread to the lymph nose I
studied myself against the door jamb the
doctor didn't seem to notice
I suspect it's in the lungs too my
knuckles whitened against the painted
wall but doctor isn't that combination
fatal only then did his eyes hollowed by
fatigue meet mine all cancer is fatal
mrs. kealoha i think that'll do it I
like to if you'd like to ask some
questions I'd be happy to take
threatened it all and your situations of
lifeforce pie
you're late with your children there
were times one time in Brazil I remember
was Annie's birthday and I got up early
to get ready and open the front living
room curtains and there was a machine
gun armed guard standing in front of the
window when I questioned you there were
two guards one in front of back he said
it was because of an oncoming imminent
revolution in fact an agent had doubled
the one in the confessionals
matter-of-fact had doubled had
threatened the lives of us the children
and me come on you must have something
else you want to know I can't see too
well longest he was away from you maybe
2 weeks 2 weeks he made a movie he went
Hollywood and he made a movie called I
was a prisoner in Siberia and he would
be gone quite a bit on that I doubt if
he started in the movie I think CIA
funded it but it had to do with it was
aimed at the Communists of Japan and it
was evidently kind of a hit at least Joe
told me it was a hit yes warden
Bennett which band he spent over a few
years how did your fellow CIA colleagues
welcome Joe
I don't think they could quite figure
mouth I don't think that well I had
trouble figuring them out I was married
to him but I don't think they could
figure him out because first of all he
had he didn't speak anything but
Japanese until he was 8 and he not only
knew the language he knew the body
language he knew when to pull back when
to press forward and he had an advantage
in that I think I think at first they
weren't real keen for the idea because
he was the first me say to be sent to
Japan as an as an operative but I think
as they got used to him and he went up
in the ranks they got to like him yeah
that would have been terrible CIA can
just imagine just look at me tonight no
thank you but that's a very nice
compliment I like to think I would the
feminist a little ahead of my time you
know helping my husband's five but at
any rate yes what was that sure your
family react your marriage
what was interesting my mother and
father who were hardly bluebloods
really welcome Joe they thought it they
thought he was great my father told me
in fact that he thought Jill was the
only man who could handle me truly but
Joe's mother was of a different mind you
in those days you don't you didn't marry
outside the race and so when he brought
a bride back when he brought me back as
his bride she was very unhappy that's
one of the reasons that she felt
threatened when she saw me because she
knew I was gonna take her son away which
I did yes how much of the other CIA wise
I didn't contact the book why didn't L
see I was writing this book you know I
didn't I never sign anything I have a
feeling they know now looking at the
display that Elizabeth has ultra
bug-eyed no I really haven't contacted
many CIA wives I see one in the audience
and I'm happy to see her smiling face
but in general it's not known this is my
own story and I just I think the agency
if they do read it instead of being
upset with me maybe they'd put a medal
on me I'm not sure any other questions
yes like I'm your children well my
children I asked them recently I have
five children three boys and two girls
and I mentioned to them recently you
know it was it hard living under the
strictures of CIA and I said Oh CIA
nothing we just thought we had strict
parents and he did have strict parents
my husband was very very strict but they
seemed to love him all the more for it
anything else cuz I'd be happy to sign
some books thank you